hola este vídeo se trata de analizar
estos números que tenemos que pusimos al
azar y queremos saber si son divisibles
por 2 3 4 5 6 9 o 10 en otro vídeo
dedicaremos tiempo a revisar los
conceptos que están atrás de la
divisibilidad pero este será más
práctico nosotros lo que vamos a hacer
es simplemente revisar si cada uno de
estos números puede ser divisible por
los números que tenemos en la lista
entonces vamos a comenzar el primero por
el 2 recuerdo
a ver vamos a comenzar por el 2 para
saber si un número es divisible entre 2
lo que tenemos que hacer es fijarnos en
la posición de las unidades y ver si el
dígito que está ocupando esta posición
es divisible entre 2 en este primer caso
hay un 8 y 8 es divisible entre 2
este número es divisible entre 2 en el
siguiente tenemos un 0 consideramos que
el 0 si es divisible entre 2 es más lo
que tenemos que fijarnos es si la
posición de las unidades es par y
entonces tanto 8 en este caso como 0 el
0 también lo consideramos par entonces
también este número también es divisible
entre 2 vamos con el último en el último
tenemos en la posición de las unidades
el dígito 505 es impar entonces no es
divisible entre 2
ahora vamos con el 3
entonces para saber si un número es
divisible entre 3 lo que tengo que hacer
es sumar todos los dígitos que componen
al número y si el resultado de la suma
es divisible entre 3 entonces el número
es divisible entre 3 a ver vamos a sumar
los que están aquí entonces tenemos 2 +
7 + 9 + 9 más cinco outs
+ 5 + 8
8 + 8
ok entonces 27 99 18 927 5 32 más 8 48
48 o sea que esté todos usen todos los
dígitos suman 48
pues 48 si es divisible entre 3 y es más
si tuvieras dudas todavía puedes sumar
en los dígitos del 48
o sea que sería 4 más 8 a ver vamos a
ponerlo
vamos a ponerlo aquí 4 no no no me gusta
y bueno
entonces 4 + 8
a ver vamos a ponerlo aquí
4 + 8 es igual a 12 y 12 si es divisible
entre 3 y si sigues teniendo dudas puede
sumar los dígitos que componen al 12 que
es 1 y 2 y 1 más dos es igual a 3 y
efectivamente el 13 es divisible entre 3
a ver entonces ahora vamos a quitar esto
que está aquí para que no estorben no
nos distraiga y vamos también a recordar
que este sumaban 12 de acuerdo la suma
de estos dos entonces el que tenemos
aquí si es divisible entre 3 ahora vamos
con el siguiente no está muy fácil este
lo podemos hacer con la mente 5 6 6 11 +
7 18 y 18 o sea este suman 18 18 si es
divisible entre 3 y otra vez si tuvieras
dudas sumas el 1 y el 8 nos da 9 y 9 es
divisible entre 3 entonces este que está
acá también es divisible entre 3
vamos con el último
bueno el último me da 100 pues es 17 8
614 5 10 y 9 pues 19 no es divisible
entre 3 así que vayamos con el siguiente
ahora vamos con el 4 para saber si un
número es divisible entre 4 yo tengo que
observar las primeras dos posiciones las
unidades y las decenas que es esto que
está aquí y observar si ese número es
divisible entre 4 entonces todo el
número será divisible entre 4 entonces
en este primer caso tengo 88 y 88 pues
si es divisible entre 4 entonces aquí
vamos a poner al 4 vámonos con el
siguiente en el siguiente en las dos
posiciones tengo 70 entonces a ver vamos
a ver el 60 si es divisible entre 4 me
faltarían 10 entonces pues no no es
divisible y podemos comprobarlo o sea
pues podrías dividir el 70
entre 44 cabe una vez en el 71 por 44
para 73 bajo el cero algo la diferencia
la diferencia es 40 y ahora este va a
caber pues el 4 en el 40 caben nueve
veces 9 por 4 36
en 44 y entonces pues efectivamente no
tenemos residuo y entonces no es
divisible entre 4 a ver vamos a quitar
nuestra operación
ok muy bien entonces ok ese tampoco es
divisible entre 4 vamos ahora con el 5
entonces para saber si un número es
divisible entre 5 lo que tengo que
observar es que el primer dígito el
dígito de las unidades sea 5 ó 0 así de
simple
entonces en este primer caso pues no es
ni cinco ni cero entonces no es
divisible entre 5 en el segundo caso
tenemos un 0 entonces este número si es
divisible entre 5
vayamos al último en el último tenemos
por fin este número si es divisible
entre 5 de acuerdo porque la primer
posición en las unidades tiene un 5
vamos ahora con el 6
el 6 para saber si un número es
divisible entre 6 lo que tenemos que
observar es que sea divisible entre 2 y
3 porque los factores primos de 6 son 2
y 3 pero tiene que ser simultáneamente
divisible entre 2 y 3 no nada más 1
entonces vamos con el primero
efectivamente el primero es divisible
entre 2 y 3 por lo tanto es divisible
entre 6 el segundo número pues también
ocurre que simultáneamente es divisible
entre 2 y 3 entonces también es
divisible entre 6 y en el tercero pues
no aparece ni el 2003 entonces no puede
ser divisible entre 6
vamos con el 9
a ver vamos con el 9 para saber si un
número es divisible entre 9 el
procedimiento es muy similar a lo que
hicimos con el 3 o sea tenemos que sumar
todos los dígitos y si el resultado es
divisible entre 9 entonces el número es
divisible entre 9 pero ya tenemos echar
las cuentas o sea por ejemplo aquí suma
48 que no es divisible entre 9 y también
suma 12 de acuerdo y tampoco es
divisible entre 9 entonces este primer
número no es divisible entre 9 el
segundo número sus dígitos suman 18 y 9
por 2 es 18 o sea si es un 18 es un
múltiplo de 9 entonces en este caso este
número si es múltiplo de 9 y en el
último caso pues observamos en el 19 no
es divisible entre 9 entonces ese número
pues no es divisible entre 9 vámonos con
el último y para saber si un número es
divisible entre 10 pues es el más fácil
de todos simplemente tengo que observar
la posición de las unidades
si es 0 entonces el número es divisible
entre 10 pero aquí no hay un 0 entonces
no es divisible entre 10 pero aquí sí lo
hay entonces este número lo va a poner
aquí abajo también también es divisible
entre 10 y el último número tiene un 5
entonces no es divisible entre 10
y haremos más vídeos para tratar el tema
de la divisibilidad pero por lo pronto
con este ya terminamos que te diviertas
y nos vemos en el próximo